hi we're the cast of Nancy Drew I'm
Madison jozani I play best Marvin I'm
Kennedy McMahon and I play Nancy Drew
I'm the Lewis and I play George Van
Houten's you can see him and I play Nick
I'm Alex axe and I play bass and we are
playing who's who I think Nancy and I
are very similar senses of humor I think
we're both very meticulous sharp
intelligent on a independence all of
this inquiry curious yeah really
yes I think so I mean here mr. mechanic
man I mean yeah I haven't got a criminal
past I have so many secrets you have no
idea oh that's really gonna settle the
accomplisher person you've got I feel
like yeah just love the secret stuff
it's very nosey she's got a good yeah
yeah I never have but I am sure
excellent
[Music]
I'm gonna don't you do it just don't you
just likes deciding that the job I said
I was ill and I did feel a bit sick but
then I thought I might as well come in
like late and she was really angry at me
my boss yes oh yeah did you keep the job
[Laughter]
I just feel like you're really with it
well in that case I'd say I am quite
with it maybe know what internet slang
because I still have to like work with
like the TT FM TIG Jo GI Joe kind of
thing but like I'm gonna making up my
own words I didn't know what that was
Hey Wow
I just I think it's a good platform a
very negative platform in many ways but
you make it very positive I make it
worse probably oh stop like wanna
dashing I'm gonna say something really
boring like broccoli tastes a lot of raw
vegetables calm down I'm good I'm gonna
go I'm gonna go this way
yeah I think okay I think so too
I like a luxurious it's very meditative
yeah she runs a bath bath bombs Alex
does meditate before he does anything
he's always like I'll be I'll be ready
in 20 minutes I'm two meditators I think
hmm because he does improv and then he
does she's just like on it Nene's like
yeah she's in Nene no all of us we're
all in long-term relationships we know
we all have a crush on Scott wolf
wherever he is we have like fake crushes
I liked enough mm-hmm I'm quite good at
nothing but I don't have to nap at work
because I hate waking up and then having
to work yeah my boyfriend thinks I've
got a problem because I like to no but I
did have three naps okay it's just nice
shake a little 20 yeah just - okay cool
mmm oh I think you - and what can I say
- I think these two I'm gonna show you
soon I've never had a advise of you -
not good - yeah well not just like love
advice I mean friendship like
relationships in general advice these
two for sure and me sometimes
and she's good she's great it's not from
Bambi I don't know why I've been
obsessed with that song for like five
years now it just pops into my head and
honestly whatever plays I just I love
singing to myself anything eminent a lot
of silly pictures for this one can take
a lot of blank at like the top half of
your face and the minority Riley should
be like downstairs at the table like
she'll be the first question oh I'm a
planner and organizer okay 750 p.m.
we'll meet here is extenuate and if you
walk here and then you go there and then
we'll all be there and open respite in
this one with her hot yoga and him to
drink wine more than yoga but yeah wine
yoga dinner yeah that's my life do you
might do my face oh I was late I'm sorry
I'll be there in a second you have to
catch me in the moment
[Music]
[Music]